TIM BRAY: Hi there.
Thanks for tuning in.
My name's Tim Bray, and I
work in the Identity group
at Google.
Today with me I have--
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
My name is Breno,
and I'm an engineer with
the Identity team at Good.
TIM BRAY: He's being modest.
He's the tech lead
with the Identity team
I work with at Google.
So there's been a lot of news
just over the last few weeks
about this major
horrific password
dump exposed on
the open internet.
I don't want to mention
the company's name,
because they're good people.
We got nothing against them.
But the numbers are
kind of spine-chilling.
We're talking about north
of 100 million username,
password records dumped out
there into the open space.
And this might be the
biggest such leak ever.
Really, how bad is it?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
I think there's,
to some extent, an
overreaction, in the sense
that we've had occasional
breaches like this, perhaps
not to exactly this
magnitude, but large breaches.
And those are
repeated occurrences.
So it's something
that we sort of
come to expect that you're going
to hear about large password
databases being compromised
and leaked into the internet.
TIM BRAY: So why is it bad?
Why is this a bad thing?
What problems does it cause?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Well,
obviously for the company
that lost the password database,
it's an embarrassing event.
And it's also an
inconvenience for the users,
because they're going to force
their users to sort of recover
their accounts.
TIM BRAY: That's right.
I had to change mine.
Yep.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
Some users might have
difficulty doing this,
so they will probably
lose a number of customers
after that event.
And so there's a big impact
to the company involved.
But for the users, there
is also a big impact,
because many users have a
small number of passwords
that they reuse across sites.
And so what is going to happen
is once the developers crack
these passwords and they have
the association of the username
to the password, they can
attempt to compromise accounts
in other sites using
those credentials.
TIM BRAY: Right.
But the passwords
were encrypted,
so shouldn't we be safe?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
It actually depends
a lot on the type of
encryption that was used.
For instance, when you have
encryption or hashing that
doesn't involve salts,
then techniques,
such as Rainbow Tables, which
is a highly parallelizable
technique so attackers can, for
instance, run jobs in any cloud
service and crack a very large
percentage of the database,
given some amount of time.
TIM BRAY: This is
really bad stuff.
And many of the people who
listen to the GDL series here
are app developers themselves.
So what can we
tell app developers
to avoid them
being the next news
story about their passwords
having been dumped?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
As an app developer,
you're worried
about the reputation
of your app.
You're worried
about losing users
once they can't
recover account stuff
during an event like this.
And if you can't afford
to invest this security
effort to protect your
password database,
it's better to not be in the
business of having passwords
to start with and managing them.
TIM BRAY: Roughly
speaking, give me
a rough idea of the
scale at which Google
does this kind of work
at protecting them.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Google has
a fairly large security team.
We are talking about
hundreds of people,
considering not only the
core of the security team
but also embedded security
people in other teams.
And also, many of them are
well-known professionals
that had a reputation
established
before they joined Google.
The security
community is growing,
but it's a skill that
is in short supply.
TIM BRAY: Right.
And let's be honest.
My opinion is that in the case
of the big internet companies,
most of them are pretty good.
Facebook, to be honest,
is really quite good.
So if I'm going to do that, get
out of the password business
and rely on Google or Facebook
or Twitter or Microsoft
or whoever for that, that's a
pretty tough decision to take.
I'm going to put my
eggs in their basket.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
TIM BRAY: How do I get
comfortable with making
that kind of a decision?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS:
I think it just
starts with a realistic
assessment of how good a job
you can do in-house.
I think it's very
easy to see the risks.
What happens if
the system is down?
Or what happens if the system
has been compromised itself?
As opposed to understanding
your internal risks.
Many people think that the
internet companies are divided
into the ones that know
that they have been hacked
and the ones that don't.
And so do you really
have a good grasp on what
is happening, in terms of
security of environment?
Can you assess the
risk correctly?
Can you assess the cost and
how often your system will not
be operational also?
So you have to make a
cost-benefit analysis
with all the risks involved and
look at the operational records
of these companies and assess
it as any other technology
or outsource service
you might use.
TIM BRAY: Right.
Let me expand on one point
that Breno made there.
He's talked about the companies
that know they've been hacked
and the ones that don't.
Two things from that.
Even the best companies
get hacked sometimes.
I sit here at Google, and I see
emails go by sometimes saying,
oh, obscure cross-site scripting
vulnerability discovered
in line 8,035 of this file here.
I guess the difference is
that at a place like Google
we have people whose
job it is to notice that
and to fix it when it happens.
The thing that really
troubles me is not
so much the individual
site getting hacked
is when a popular web framework,
like Node.js or Rails, gets
hacked and has a
zero-day vulnerability,
you're looking at 100,000
sites all of a sudden
being wide open to attack.
So let me follow up.
Let me just emphasize
a point you just made
or get you to do that.
You said, well, you have to
do a cost-benefit analysis.
It sounds like the
same kind of thing
you do when you outsource
your financials or your HR.
Is that really a good
way to think about it?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: I'm sure if
you outsource your financials
you are taking a set of
risks that would be different
if you kept them in-house.
So yes, I would
say it's similar.
In addition to the
cost-benefit ratio,
you also need to look at
the realistic, like measures
of the benefit.
Because you may have
additional benefits.
You may reduce friction
on account sign up,
and you might reduce
friction on login.
Because if the users
come to your site
and they are already
logged in to an Identity
Provider, such as
Google or Facebook
or a common Identity
Provider, Microsoft,
they will probably have
an easier time logging
into your site.
And so you might see increased
measures of user engagement,
of account creation
and user acquisition.
In addition to the
standard cost-benefit ratio
of outsourcing some
technology, there
is potentially a
large untapped benefit
that you are missing out on.
TIM BRAY: Fair enough.
That's a good point.
Perhaps the most crucial
point in the relationship
between your app and
a user is that moment
when they first sign up, right?
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
TIM BRAY: And
anything you can do
to reduce the friction of
getting somebody signed
up and on board is a
major business plus.
And if you can do that and
reduce risk at the same time--
Now if you really must be
in the password business,
if for some reason, regulatory
reasons or whatever,
you must be in the
password business,
there's a lot of good online
resources about how to hash
and how to crypt and
how to salt and so on.
If you were going
to do this, what
would be your top couple
of recommendations?
I guess the first
one would be don't.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Right.
I think the actual security
of implementing the password
system is, in some
sense, the easiest one
to get it right, because there
are good references online.
The hardest thing to do
is the overall integrity
of your password operations.
You are going to have to expose
the password verification
system eventually to
a login box somewhere.
And then you have to worry about
your whole stack leading up
to the point where you contact
your password database to have
security in depth
so you can have
multiple roadblocks
to a developer
actually gaining administrative
control over your password
system and extracting
the password database.
I think that's the hard
part, quite frankly.
TIM BRAY: Fair enough.
But our recommendation
would be don't do it.
Get out of the
password business.
Thank you for tuning in.
Breno and I are both
pretty easy to find online.
If you are interested in these
issues, get in touch with us
directly.
And once again, thank
you for tuning in.
BRENO DE MEDEIROS: Thank you.